right so you've come to Yuki from the
Middle East yes yep and you've seen
Sharia in action yeah yeah pretty give
me a couple of examples of what you
witnessed using women being told you
know you contrast a certain way and the
Islamic please well I grew up in the UAE
but I've been to Saudi Arabia as well
where there's a lot of please what walk
up to me and they'll be like oh don't
speak to any woman don't look at any
women or else you know you'll be jail
and you'll put her in trouble too and
I've also been to the Holy Land on Mac
where there's a lot of pilgrims and
always it feels like as if they always
brag about Brotherhood unity but I've
seen a lot racism and oppression of
women you know covered up and little
girls begging outside but no one's
giving them any money and Islamic
release will just chase the Mafia and
that was the first time when I realized
you know maybe this whole unity thing is
an illusion
you know yeah so it should be a lot of
good thing you reppin you I mean
compared to the West no no I mean I
rather have people being open to be
wherever like when I was younger they
told me you know don't draw up like
humans so animals because it's against
against the religion you know spare you
just focus on certain academic studies